- Well today we have a bunch of working women.
It's nine to five.
We're celebrating that. - I know, I love it.
- So I wanna know,
(audience clapping)
So I wanna know like if you had to pick one person,
I'm sure there's many,
but if you had to pick one person,
the most influential woman in your life,
who would you say that is?
- This is a two parter.
So number one would be my mom,
who's been such a--
(audience clapping) - That's awesome.
- She's been the quintessential rock of the family.
Gone through tough times. - That's funny. (laughs)
- She is, yeah, I'm the pebble, she's the real rock.
(laughing)
But so, I would say her,
and then certainly after being
with Lauren my wife now for over 10 years,
and just when I watch her over the years
and certainly with our babies,
and her doing everything that she possibly can
to make sure that it's as normal as it could possibly be,
our babies have good perspective,
and handling the household,
handling me which can be a big pain in the butt,
our life, the complexities that that brings.
And I also, I was talking to her last night,
so we moved in the past three years
since our babies have been born,
over 25 times for my work in three years.
Now when I say we've moved, she's moved,
like the babies, and the house, and the dogs,
and the things like that.
- That's love.
- And I look at her, I'm like you are my superwoman.
So it would have to be Lauren, yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
(audience clapping)
I would not like moving that much.
(laughing) - I know.
- I mean I guess I've traveled on the road for years,
but at least it's one bus everywhere.
Yeah, it's like a home base,
but oh my gosh, okay.